i've been getting into like the uh you
know the youtube channels that uh really
look into the indium scammers like i
think jim browning yeah
i'm a big fan of them all yeah i i
really love what jim browning does and i
don't know what like uh i don't know
some of the other people as well some of
the people who actually just phone them
back up as well and just really troll
them i remember i saw one guy who got an
indian scammer so [ __ ] angry that he
was literally shouting yeah on the phone
have you watched like uh it was like
yeah kit bogar
he does ones where he does like uh like
uh what's the inverse speed runs i guess
slow round oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he
tries to keep them on the phone for as
long as possible yeah yeah and i swear
he's he on average gets it like four or
five hours holy [ __ ] and just wastes
that time he's far too good at sounding
like an old grandmother yeah he's not an
american grandma
he's he's he's too good he's a filter
but he also like does a really good job
yeah and he's got the mannerisms down
perfectly because he just does it all
day yeah yeah
so he's there pretending to be an old
grandma for like six hours
it's insane
he works with the voice coach apparently
oh really oh my god
this is that's someone dedicated to this
i've seen people get like nine hours
though [ __ ] cool
and then yeah and then at the end the
reveal is so great because you could
just hear like how [ __ ] annoyed the
person
also these scammers get so [ __ ] angry
yeah fast enough yeah you hear some of
them where they're like like no got the
warm-up now get the google play card now
now you dumb [ __ ] they're like shouting
at them it's like oh yeah this is some
good question
this is still better than like virgin
media uk as well still
i remember because like i what uh what
clocks me onto that was like it was
recommended that i got recommended just
a random clip of just an indie guy like
shouting at full [ __ ] volume just
like why are you so dumb why are you so
stupid why are you doing that and i'm
just like what the [ __ ] yeah if you like
clicked the wrong thing yeah yeah it's
like traumatizing for these older people
yeah i bet
jesus christ like someone could murder
my mother and i don't think i'd be as
angry as that like jesus christ
like what the hell man
there's some really good jim browning
ones where he like gets to like passport
information on their pc and he like
shows it to them it's really [ __ ]
good
yeah yeah yeah
check out jim browning if you are like
if you ever want to fall down a rabbit
hole and uh just wonder what is actually
on the other side of whoever like phones
up
phones you up and tries to scam people
all right good i mean if every one of
those people that's uh calling them back
and [ __ ] with them it's uh saves you
know one person's uh money and time yeah
i mean that if anyone deserves to be
[ __ ] with it's it's scams scammers
right yeah because you know even if you
you're quite savvy with this stuff it is
you know you're unlikely to if you hear
an indian accent calling you and telling
you hey you need to pay ex money to
microsoft you're probably not going to
fall for it but yeah you know
that's because we know yeah but also the
old people older generation have no idea
right yeah
i have a distinct memory from when i was
like
of my mum coming to me being like you
know our friend apparently microsoft
called them up and said that they have
some of the worst viruses in the world
on their pc
and i was like wow really really that's
all i heard of it a week later she comes
back she's like turns out it was a scam
and they lost
and they lost 1 000 pounds
just for inflation that's like 10 grand
they said that they had the y2k bug
this was
young and i just have this weird memory
being like that sounds strange that
sounds dumb
why would microsoft call you up why
would they not just nuke your pc yeah
right
the thing that i've had to teach my
parents is like if there were those
there was a period when they just were
not tech savvy at all i mean like they
still don't exactly take savvy but at
least they were not tech savvy enough to
even attempt to go on the internet and
go on facebook and do that stuff and it
was the point where they started to take
more of an interest of being online and
stuff like that that it really was kind
of like stepping on eggshells when
trying to explain to them that some
emails are not real and some emails are
scams and it's just like some sometimes
sometimes my mom just like will send me
a message to be like is this is should i
click on this link should i click on
that and like i don't know how to
properly convey
which sometimes like which emails are
legit and which emails are not legit
it's kind of like explaining to someone
over the phone how to defuse a bomb
sometimes i told my parents all right i
said even if you get the email saying
your account's been hacked or anything
like that yeah i said i told them and
the same with numbers as well uh because
my dad
nearly i think nearly fell for one a few
times
and i always told him just just call
them back like call the go like if you
get called by your bank go to the bank's
website call them yeah yeah you know
just immediately don't talk yeah because
you know odds are your bank isn't going
to call you and if they do they'll
probably ask you a bunch of weird stuff
yeah if all like you know any like
social media gets compromised quote
unquote from an email then just go
directly to the website and check yeah
so yeah yeah i nearly [ __ ] fell for
that uh the google adsense thing yeah
fell for it yeah yeah yeah i actually
didn't get that really yeah dude you're
lucky man if jim browning fell for it
anyone can yeah i saw his video on it
actually
it is it's waringly convincing but
that's the thing right it's like it's
hard to like convey to you you know your
parents or your grandparents like yeah
you know how to identify between a scam
email not a scandal because i feel every
year it's just get like that line is
getting narrower
it's getting too good which is why like
which is why i find it so hard to
explain to them because sometimes i say
i have to like second guess myself
and i'm just like if i'm second-guessing
myself
and i literally grew up on the inside i
work on the internet yeah
how can my parents who have little to no
knowledge of internet culture
tell the difference how am i supposed to
convey that through text or through
phone to be like just just don't believe
any email you get sent basically